Good morning, John.
Last time, you came to us from the beautiful
canals of Venice, Italy, and so today I come
to you from the beautiful canals of Venice,
Florida. I totally did not plan this.
John, the discussion of whether or not George
Washington was an evil person has spread like
wild fire across Nerdfighteria, spawning many
interesting and intelligent discussion both
in Your Pants and in the comments.
I like the concept of a What-if machine. Just
so that we can go back and see what happened
if we shove someone into the street, prevent
a butterfly from flapping its wings. I like
that there was a Nerdfighter called Deflin
in Your Pants who decided that we should actually
work up a list of criteria for what it takes
to get into the Evil Baby orphanage, and I
like that most of the discussion was focused
on intent. If we wanted to be good people
then, kind of, we are.
Though I don’t know that that’s precisely
true, and I start to get a little screwed
up here because I start to realize that it’s
not that important that we figure out what
makes a bad person because I know that I’m
not a bad person, and as kneehighargylesocks
pointed out in the comments, Sirius Black
did tell Harry Potter that you can’t separate
the world into good people and Death Eaters;
it’s more complicated than that. And I know
that I’m not a Death Eater, but I don’t
know that I’m not a good person, and I want
to be a good person, so I want to know what
the criteria for being a good person is. But
that’s not something that we necessarily
intrinsically know.
John, a couple years ago I sat on this very
dock right here and I talked about how objectively
bad the practice of eating meat is, and that’s
still true; the production of meat still accounts
for about the same amount of greenhouse gasses
as the transportation sector. Yes, that includes
driving. And if we took all of the edible
food that we feed to livestock in this country,
and instead of feeding it to livestock gave
it to people, no one in the world would be
hungry. And yet I still eat meat. I know that
it’s bad, but I keep doing it because I
like it.
I recently read in Good Magazine; I don’t
know if you know what Good Magazine is, but
it’s a magazine, and I recently read that
they’re challenging their readers to not
eat meat for the month of June, and so I think
I’m gonna try to do that. Uhh, though I’m
not going to succeed entirely because I’m
with my in-laws right now, and I have to eat
whatever they give me because I have to be
gracious. Also it’s really tasty. But I’m
not that likely to get really excited about
that idea, like I wanna eat meat, and so not
eating meat isn’t fun.
I do get excited about technological solutions,
like a bunch of scientists are trying to figure
out how to grow meat in a laboratory, much
more efficiently and without the need for,
uh, suffering of an animal. And everyone I
know, EVERYONE, when I tell them this idea,
they’re like “Bleurgh blurgaka blegh blerugh
bleuurgh,” and I’m like “For real? You
think that there’s something grosser than
the way we currently produce food?” Because
no, no there’s nothing grosser than the
way we currently produce food.
Also I find this hilarious - the United States
just, uh, revamped the food pyramid into a
plate in which half of the plate is vegetables
and fruits, which is fantastic. And the other
half of the plate is protein and grains. I
think that the protein is hilarious because
there’s tons of protein in vegetables and
tons of protein in grains. So what is up with
that? Why is there a protein section at all?
That would be because this whole thing is
being designed by the United States Department
of Agriculture and not the Department of Health,
and the agriculture industry of America, uh,
surprise, surprise, thrives on meat eating.
So, yeah, it’s a little bit disturbing that
the, ah, United States Department of Agriculture
is - is controlling, uh, the largest part
of our health equation, obesity being the
number one health problem in America right
now.
So Nerdfighters, if you can find it in your
heart, go a little bit vegetarian this month.
See how it takes you. Maybe you could just
be a lunchaterian, maybe you could just eat
meat on the weekends. Try it out, knowing
that denying yourself this one indulgence
actually, uh, is going to make you a little
bit better of a person, which will decrease
your chances of someone coming back in time
and robbing you from your cradle as a baby
and sending you to a Evil Baby Orphanage.
There’s links in the description with more
information on all of this stuff.
John, I’ll see you on Monday.